you
[Applause]
okay so we've signed up there's no
turning back now so you think you know
about sex chances are you don't and we
are here to tell you that you don't we
are here to tell you that no matter
where you come from Abuja to Alabama why
to downtown London six has and continues
to change and we need to understand this
if we're gonna keep things safe and
spicy so now the act of rubbing our
naked bodies together has undergone a
number of changes and those changes have
been affected by eons of ideas even you
as an adult have some internalized ideas
about sex that you never challenge some
good some bad and some very very strange
so when you allow someone to see you
butt naked do you ever think about how
the ideas that you internally have will
affect whether you will like them
tickling your elbow or kissing your
thigh or shouting out the name of a
chosen deity one must do internal
monitoring and evaluation if we are
gonna live our best sexy lives and we're
gonna tell you how to have a great sex
life right but the first thing you need
to do is let go of the bad ideas you
have about sex think about the things
that we need to change and the things we
need to embrace in all of their shiny
newness so we're gonna take you on a
journey of sex the bad parts of sex
historically great sexual practices and
the future of sex now judging by the
cool 7 billion people on this planet
human beings have been doing the sex
thing for a long time and in vast
quantities but this does not mean we are
actually good at it from the top of my
head rape culture how tradition and
culture limits
ideas of pleasure or even the idea that
the nipple deserves the same treatment
that a DJ gives his dick when he is
trying to turn up the volume like that
is a personal pet peeve of mine we are
so scared of sex and we need somebody to
blame for our fear
until women and our fear of every part
of their Anatomy unless were the ones
using their sexiness think about it you
can quite easily go to someone and say
my elbow hurts but try going to someone
and saying excuse me my vagina has a
strange buzzing feeling do you know
where I can find the buzzing vagina
ointment and see how well that goes down
does not go down well I once challenged
friends to simply go into supermarkets
and say to strangers sighs no one did it
despite the fact that they could have
been talking about chicken or turkey so
a number of cultural and historical
notions have borrowed so deeply within
us we don't even notice that it's
strange to freak out when somebody says
nipple as opposed to left-knee we refuse
to engage with sex properly and the
first step is admitting that it exists
outside of trying to sell us products
like bottled water or coffee the
unrealistic depictions and movies or
that one thing that you saw on the
internet by mistake mm-hmm so now in
order to cure this ailment again let us
just first admit that we have some
messed up ideas of sex and breathe in
and a little all go now it all seems
pretty morbid that culture and society
have failed us in our quest for coitus
but this is not the case there are
things that the past can teach us to
help us upgrade the present so now if I
had a glass of merlot which I really
wish I did I would pour the ancestors a
drink because there are ways in which
African societies handles this sex thing
before the sea that shall not be named
came through we had within African
societies we had spaces both social and
spiritual that helped institutionalize
healthy sexual practices we had
sexuality schools that taught social and
erotic cues we had spaces where
teenagers could engage understand and
like properly know how to handle sexual
urges and places where adults could
handle the stresses and Strife's of
adulting where is the dinning
you hiding your credit card bill or
deleting that toll-free number from your
phone these spaces of older was so
important for women there were African
sexual practices that centered women and
in particular their pleasure and we're
going to talk about one in particular
that named oceanology
also known as the African erotic yes my
people welcome to the Thunderdome the
erotic takes on different shapes and
forms as you travel the globe now let's
take a bow to the Kama Sutra the world's
first book on the pleasures of sensual
living more than just a mere depiction
of contortionist sexual positions it's
provided a comprehensive guide on living
a good life what is particularly
interesting for us is that it it's
focused on women and creating pleasure
for women mm-hmm shout out to the Kama
Sutra but back to the African erotic
okay my bad bringing it back so Carranza
who says that uh soon who is an Alicia
of the Yoruba people typically
associated with water purity fertility
love and most importantly sensuality
represents a female centered life
transforming energy that causes through
and animates life
she says that women who typify the ocean
force brandish their sexuality quite
openly and unselfconsciously so she goes
on to say well you gotta got that line
this time so the flow need not result in
conception and birth but doesn't tell
the principle of pleasure at the heart
of copulation this pleasure principle at
the heart of the creative energy is
metaphorically known as ocean honey
sorry I did not want to misquote that so
now ocean honey and ocean ality
reaffirmed the normality of sexual
pleasure and the erotic Oshun like other
female deities the fertility across
Africa made sure and emphasized the
importance of female sexuality without
negating male sexuality we had the Tonga
the member the Sundy and other similar
sexuality schools of thought that taught
young women about the power of this
inner force
so within the African continent there is
a great deal of talk about the synergic
nature of sex and how it comes together
as a social good for example within
Rwanda there is the notion that the
rivers are replenished by the act of a
woman squirting hmm but modern-day ideas
or sex have become some sort of battle
in which we are all trying to subvert
each other we are pounding the [__]
using sex as a weapon playing
hard-to-get
conquering a constant power struggle and
there is always a loser when it comes to
this war so now the ability to openly
brandish and explore your sexuality and
your sex without it being a threat to
others is at the core of engaging with
healthy sexual practices now this is
where it begins to get really really
good so what does it mean to rican
sexualized sex away from this idea of
the monster hiding in the night what is
the potential for doing greatness on the
kitchen counter a secluded beach the
back seat of a car or even simply in
between the sheets now in learning from
the past and sliding into the present a
radical theory of sex must identify and
must describe explain and denounce
sexual oppression and the erotic
injustice and sex positivity is one of
the realms in which the new can be
unpacked and explored we are asking you
to call upon the ocean honey to engage
with ideas of new ideas of sex and
pleasure so that we can start to build a
new identity that feels more like a
fitted dress and less like a wooden
cousin slowly choking the life out of us
now there are a lot of people charging
their own sexual parts but because as
hala Africa we do sex and sexuality
online we would be foolhardy not to
mention the digital realm there are
women who are online creating incredible
conversations chatting about the
clitoris chatting about the reverse
cowgirl and also cunnilingus I like the
word cunnilingus I've
you do but that's not the point anyway
these women are resurrecting the work of
our ancestors to have some incredible
conversations that have been previously
buried and sealed they are asking the
questions that we are so afraid to ask
so that we don't end up in sticky
situations that's true and another space
that we've been seeing the charting of a
new sexual part is by queer women and
their engagement in kink now think Fifty
Shades of Grey was out the creepy rich
guy who does not understand consent so
one fascinating subject of kink is
actually rope play oops
shimmery also known as kinbaku is the
Japanese art of rope play originally
used as a means of restraining captives
it became sexualized and spreading
across the globe as a kinky form of
restraint with a respected and erotic
aesthetic and it landed on our shores
who would have thought that African
queer women would be Kingston's coming
from a history of sexual violence
slavery and a lack of bodily autonomy is
it not too soon you asked no it's not
and these women have taught us that
despite the dark history that covers the
body of women from our beautiful
continent these women are actively and
beautifully constructing what sex and
pleasure means to them this is not to
say that everyone now needs to rush out
and engage in kink but if these queer
women can come out of a history of again
sexual violence slavery colonization and
all manner of traditional religious and
cultural pitfalls to reconceptualize
what sex and pleasure means to them then
you can do it too
you can do it too boo boo it isn't
taking the ideas that we have about sex
the bad ones and head-butting them
holding on to the good ones and creating
new ones that we can have an incredible
engagement with one of the most prolific
and natural human acts ever it's about
figuring out what counts as a system bug
what to term a classic and what new
features we should add
human beings are infamous for their
superpower to upgrade this should count
for our sex too
[Applause]
[Music]